who's the most interesting person you
were locked up with Lyfe Jennings just
shared he was locked up with Jeffrey
Dahmer I was busted with um well I I ran
into uh I ran into a few rappers like
that I looked at looked up to um I ran
into um
um Drew down yeah for the year man yeah
he was in Susanville I ran to Drew down
I ran to um sugar-free I ran into
um goldilock but the most interesting
one that I ran into was a porn star out
of the valley right here his name was
Philip Oliver his poor name was oh I
don't know but anyways he was a porn
star and like his stories were just the
best
stories yeah you know what I'm saying so
to me he was the most interesting
because everybody else I could relate I
heard all that [ __ ] you know what I'm
saying but this fool is a beast you know
what I'm saying he was Legend out here
sugar-free had to be I mean he's a cool
sugar-free was a trip but he wasn't
talking to us like right like what you
see on the streets that's not how he is
in there you know I don't know if
because you know he's he's sober or what
it is you know what I'm saying but he's
just different